so does he want us to record an intro I
don't know let's just skip the intro hey
welcome to the show with no
advertisements
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
hello everybody and welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less I'm Joshua fields Milburn and I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists thank you so much for
joining us this is episode number 9
actually this is probably about episode
9.3 at this point yeah
we've tried to record this episode two
other times and we failed yesterday when
we sat down to record this for a second
time we were bought maybe half an hour
into the episode and I just looked at
Ryan at one point said we are both
incoherent it's like we were both
speaking just I'll have some alien
language ransom this whole time I
thought we were like superhuman but it
turns out after an hour interview on NPR
it kind of drains us a little bit yes so
we did an interview in the morning
yesterday and they came over here to the
asymmetrical press offices to record
this episode of the podcast episode 9
and what we wanted to talk about is what
we're calling this episode next so we
want to talk about what happens after
the decluttering after letting go of the
excess stuff you know often people think
that minimalism is about getting rid of
your stuff just getting the clutter out
of the way getting rid of material
possessions and that is true that's sort
of the initial bite at the Apple that
changes everything for us but ultimately
the the purpose of minimalism has to do
with the benefits we experience once
we're on the other side of decluttering
so removing the clutter from our lives
is not the end result it is merely the
first step I think we feel a weight
lifted off our shoulders right away but
we don't experience lasting contentment
by just getting rid of our stuff
minimalism doesn't work like that it's
possible to get rid of everything you
own and still be utterly miserable to
come home to an empty house and sulk
after removing all your pacifiers and so
today we want to talk about what happens
after we let go but before we get into
our listener questions and voicemails is
through
minder as most of you know we have a
documentary coming out on May 24th two
guys Allison love this theme yes you're
gonna awesome love it indeed we're so
excited about it so proud of what we've
got going on here but we also need your
help so we have screenings in about 160
hundred and 70 theaters so far we're
going to have about 400 theaters by the
time the movie comes out with our
distributor gather films and they're
helping us get this out to as many
people as possible but we have some
theaters that are selling out already
which is really awesome we have a lot of
theatres who still need a lot of help so
there's a really good chance that this
documentary is already screening in your
city or town or suburb and all you have
to do is go to minimalism film comm
click on see the film and reserve your
tickets because there are other theaters
that don't have enough reservations yet
and we can't actually play the film in
your theater until we have enough
reservations there and so if you just go
to minimalism film comm click on see the
film and if we don't have a screening in
your area that's okay you can actually
just request a screening so if you live
in a suburb somewhere and you have a
theater nearby we have relationships
with 3300 theaters across the United
States so you have the opportunity if
there isn't a showing close to you you
can bring the film to your town hey Josh
how does my friend in Zimbabwe get the
film good news we're doing our
theatrical run United States first and
then we're moving on to Canada and
Australia or we're still working out the
details and the dates on Canada and
Australia and we're also working on some
overseas distribution I don't know
whether or not Zimbabwe where they are
they fall in the whole chain there but
we will have other distribution and
eventually the Thome will be available
online as well so everyone's gonna have
an opportunity to see this film we're so
excited to share with you if you want to
see the trailer which is phenomenal our
director Matthew Vela is a genius you
can see the trailer it's about two and a
half minutes long over at minimalism
film calm let's get start with the show
let's listen to our first voicemail
question and this one's from Casey hey
Casey I'm in the Air Force down in
Florida and I read everything that
remains at the end of my marriage and I
did nothing but make my life awesome
after
I read it I had a question for you guys
and it was easy for me to get rid of
stuff I thought it was funny you guys
said a free back there you said it
there's three types of minimis ones like
yeah I want to do this but it's going to
take a long time and the other ones are
not one is you know know that I could
never do that
second one is uh yeah I want to do it's
going to take some time my third one is
you know where's the dumpster and I was
me what were some of the activities that
you guys kind of had to cut out that you
didn't necessarily think at first would
be easy to one it's kind of a silly
example but out of ploy station and you
know it's fun to play but when I'm
playing it obviously I'm not really
doing anything with my life you know
you're just going to sit in front of a
TV doing nothing so well you know what
was some of the stuff like that that you
guys have to try to get rid of so first
off Casey uh thank you for your service
down there in Florida really really
appreciate it well not just down there
in Florida but but overseas as well and
congratulations that you're able to let
go so easily that's awesome and I think
from most of us that's the most
difficult thing the the average American
household has more than three hundred
thousand items in it and and that's not
me just going around counting people
stuff that's according to the Los
Angeles Times we look at the things in
our lives and we get overwhelmed we
don't know where to start and for you
being able to let go of a lot of the
stuff and saying hey we're in a dumpster
throw it all out and move on with your
life but what were some of the
activities that we got rid of I like to
do stoical experiments from time to time
so for me back in 2009 when I first
discovered minimalism I got rid of TV
when I when I first moved and I remember
Ryan came over to my apartment I was
like where's your TV man you've got a TV
you got a TV anchor on your wall to hang
it awesome nice big TV where's your nice
big TV that goes there right because
that's what you're supposed to do right
and I I just said you know I moved in
this new place I kind of don't get a lot
of value from it but my problem with TV
is I would come home and just turn it on
and be like a fireplace going in the
background all the time and sort of this
this amount of white noise but the
problem with that is it kept me from
focusing on what I
actually need to do in front of me
weather was responding to emails are
doing something creative or reading a
book because let's face it if you have
the TV turned on you're sitting on the
couch from the TV it makes concentrating
on reading a book much more difficult or
whatever else you're trying to do and so
I found myself attempting to multitask
and I really wasn't actually I wasn't
getting anything done because I was so
spread out on this multitasking
multitask really it just means lack of
focus
it's a synonymous with unfocused and and
so I was doing that and I found that by
removing the TV from my life I was able
to start focusing a lot more on things
were more important to me it doesn't
mean that I think there's anything
inherently wrong with with television I
don't own I still don't want a TV now
but I do watch some TV shows from time
to time on our last podcast I even
recommended a TV show the what I'll do
now is I will attend the rent them like
on iTunes and then I'll download it on
my computer and then I will watch it
with someone else and share that
experience we can obviously talk about
that experience after we have it so
that's sort of one of the experiments I
had but I found there were a lot of a
lot of things that were just getting in
my way that I removed other activities
I've done a bunch of other experiments
as well and we can talk about those but
Ryan what are some of the things that
you've you've removed from from your
life well Casey talked about having a
Playstation I had an Xbox
that was a huge pacifier for me I would
come home I can do all my emails done by
like you know 10 or 11 o'clock at night
and I'm like oh I'm just gonna play
great hold on one sec isn't that kind of
crazy yet you get up and the first thing
you did was check your blackberry cuz
you spawned a demon barrage of emails
and then at nighttime before bed you're
still responding to emails from the same
day and it's just never-ending
and so then your reward was what was yet
playing xbox so I would sit down at 10
o'clock at night or 11 o'clock at night
and I tell myself well you know I'm just
gonna sit here play Call of Duty for an
hour or hour and a half and then at 3
o'clock in the morning and you know a
12-pack of beer later god I would
finally get so sleepy I just couldn't
keep my head up anymore and then it
would just kind of kill my next day and
kill my productivity sometimes but but I
certainly got rid of that I actually had
it for a little bit after I left
the corporate world and I thought well
this is alright well now I've got more
time and you know it's okay if I if I
spend an hour to play an xbox but really
what I ended up doing was instead of
playing it for three hours I would start
playing it for six hours so quickly a
while I had to identify that this was
something that was draining my time so
when you talk about wasting hours the
thing that I waste hour is on is YouTube
YouTube is my crack I get lost in that
Bermuda Triangle of of just going
farther and farther down this this
rabbit hole of because because on
YouTube you have all these additional
videos on the side it's like irony knows
really well what I'm going to like like
cat videos you're gonna love these cat
videos well I I get lost like watching
like Canadian rap battles and all of a
sudden it's three hours later and I'm
like what am i doing like it's it's I
liken it to eating candy like if you eat
a piece of candy it is not going to kill
you and you're not going to get sick
most likely from a piece of candy it's
certainly not healthy
I'm not going to advocate anyone goes
out and eats candy or eat sugar but
eating a piece of candy it is not so
unhealthy that you're going to have some
sort of catastrophic event happen to you
but if you went to go gorge on candy for
the next 4 hours which is what I would
do with YouTube given the opportunity
then you're going to feel really sick
like sick to your stomach
the problem with YouTube is I felt sick
sort of emotionally and mentally drained
afterward like what did I just waste
four hours on back in 2011 I wrote an
essay about this I got rid of internet
at home sort of that as an accident at
first I moved and for the first few days
I realized well I don't have internet
right now and and because I was still
moving stuff around my apartment and I
said you know what I'm just going to try
for 30 days to consciously live without
internet at home it doesn't mean I don't
have access to the Internet it just
means I have to plan access to the
Internet so back then I we were in
Dayton Ohio still I'd go to Ryan's house
to to get on online or I go to the local
library down the street or a coffee shop
press coffeehouse
there in Dayton Ohio and I would play
my internet and you know what those 30
days were the 30 most productive days of
my life
I got more writing done I more I started
reading books and and I learned a lot
more about myself and my habits and
these pacifiers these these triggers
that I had I was constantly twitching
for for the Internet and the first week
was miserable because I'm like I can't
get on Facebook or I can't get on
Twitter right away and and so it was it
was difficult for me at first was
reprogramming this habit and I had to
start replacing those bad habits with
something new and so I started replacing
it with with writing or reading books or
with exercising or with having
conversations with people and doing
something productive as opposed to you
know falling down that rabbit hole now
that's not to say there's anything
inherently wrong with television or
there's anything inherently wrong with
YouTube in fact I still find value in
YouTube if I do it deliberately
in fact now if I want to get lost down
that rabbit hole the first thing I'll do
is I'll schedule an hour or two to just
get lost in YouTube I'll put it on my
calendar and that way I know like okay
I've given myself permission to spin an
hour watching you know whatever videos I
want to watch and then I move on from it
and that feels far more productive
because I have planned it out and I've
given myself permission as opposed to
treating it as a pacifier and the same
goes with video games too Jane McGonigal
wrote a book called super better and she
talks about the the positive
psychological and neurological benefits
of playing certain video games like
Tetris especially for people who have
experienced some sort of traumatic brain
injury or PTSD there are a lot of
benefits when we play video games in a
deliberate way to repair our brain in to
or to better ourselves but you're right
I think we can we can fall down that
rabbit hole and we can eat for hours
worth of candy metaphorically and and
not feel very good about our days or
ourselves as a result yeah and I just
want to reiterate when one gives up all
their pacifiers they they have to be
prepared to be a bit uncomfortable for a
while because if you're not
for that if you don't have things to
replace those activities with then it's
very very easy to go right back down
that rabbit hole Cassandra in Illinois
has a voicemail question for us what do
you do once you have gotten rid of all
of your XS and all of your stuff in your
house and do you ever feel like you
reach a plateau once you've gotten rid
of everything so do we ever reach a
plateau I think you reach a point where
there's sort of this critical mass where
you feel comfortable at a period of time
like I said if the average American
household has 300,000 items in it well
if you get rid of 90 percent yourself
you still have 30,000 items and those
30,000 items may not always add value to
your life as you move on I know when I
let go of about 90% of my stuff I was I
was 28 years old I'm 34 years old now
and the things that added value to my
life at age 28 don't necessarily add
value at age 34 so I'm constantly asking
this question does this thing add value
to my life and as our life circumstances
change the things that add value to our
lives
change as well and and here's the cool
thing about that just because something
stops adding value to my life
that is a minimal add value to someone
else's life so my willingness to let go
is really my willingness to contribute
to other people my willingness to add
value to other people's lives as well by
donating or or selling those things and
so have I ever experienced a plateau
yeah absolutely
and once you reach that plateau you have
to realize that minimalism is not a
destination minimalism for us as a tool
to eliminate the excess so we can start
to focus on what's important and I'm
reminded a Ryan of an essay that you
wrote called offbeat and toward the end
of that essay you were talking about
sort of getting yourself uncomfortable
doing something offbeat and and this is
a direct quote from the essay if you if
you're feeling stagnant or stuck you
should change your state do something
offbeat addition for a play take a
photography class take tango lessons do
cartwheels in the yard whatever you do
do not continue to do the same
old routine and so I think once we get
to a point we have to realize what Ryan
said earlier about making yourself
uncomfortable that's the place from
which you grow the most so when you feel
like you've plateaued what you're really
saying is I am in a place where I'm
other ly comfortable and that's really
the reason Ryan and I started doing this
podcast we've gotten pretty darn good at
blogging we've gotten good at writing
books we've written three books that
have done fairly well we've written five
years worth of blogs which has been
awesome and we've gotten really good at
that over time this podcast or touring
these are different ways that allow us
to grow they put us in what I call a
discomfort zone and so whenever I feel
like I'm plateauing I know I need to do
something as Ryan said offbeat something
that is going to make me uncomfortable
so I can grow but what I would say to
Cassandra is you know most journeys they
do come to an end but it's not really
about reaching the end of that journey
it's about the journey itself so if you
started decluttering and you're worried
about well what am I going to do once
this decluttering journey is over well
ask yourself why did you start to
declutter in the first place I mean for
me it was about letting go of a lot of
things so I could find a job that I
enjoyed then it carried into my health
and it carried into my relationships so
think about why did you initially start
that journey and what were the benefits
that you were planning on experiencing
from there so you know the journey may
be over but the good news is is that
there are a lot of journeys that had to
choose from let's listen to voice mail
from Erin I was just wondering how you
guys met each Piper's and how you you
know manage rotting down info and
storing it so what do you do with all
your papers I don't really have a lot of
papers these days I burn them I got rid
of most most of my paper I mean I was
trying to think as I'm listening to this
question like the different tools that I
use I do have a like a really small
moleskin notebook that I will use to
write notes down but I constantly have
with me yeah but other than that I'm
going to my smartphone to take notes
everything is nice and organized in
there on my laptop I've got you know the
fiction file where I've got some fiction
ideas that I would like to write on one
day I've got an essay file where I will
write down some essay ideas and where I
keep all the essays I've got a
for my journal which I do every once in
a while but certainly using tools like
that will help I know a lot of a lot of
young kids these days using Evernote I
don't use it too much do you use
Evernote no not a whole lot but but I
know I know a lot of folks who use and
Evernote and really love it and yeah I
tell you that the thing that Evernote
helps a lot of people with is managing a
lot of the the papers and be able to
take photographs of business cards and
being able to take photographs of even
like a journal or notebook or something
you've done and just catalog it that way
and organize it and set up different
tags in the system to organize and
digitize your paper I found the best way
for me to handle paper is to bring as
little of it into my life as possible
that way I have far less to organize
because if you're bringing in these
mounds of paper all the time yeah it
becomes a full-time job trying to to
organize and so by bringing fewer things
in and the things I do bring into my
life
I try to quickly digitize those for a
couple reasons one is if I lose the
paper it's gone there's nothing I can do
with it but if I digitize it and then
it's backed up into the cloud if I lose
my computer or lose the paper or
whatever I don't have to worry about
what was on on that piece of paper or I
can't believe I lost that photograph
when it's all digitized it's saved is
searchable as well I think Evernote
really helps out with that and of course
storing it all and the cloud is is a
great idea and so I would I would
definitely recommend digitizing and then
of course with with junk mail we have we
definitely have some recommendations for
that too yeah you can go to the
minimalists dot-com slash day fifteen
day one five yeah the the number not not
spelled out but yeah that's what Mariah
and I have done we signed up for the do
not send us junk mail now we literally
might get a couple pieces of mail every
couple days and I know the mail that we
get it's important and I don't have to
sit there and go through a bunch of crap
don't you hate when you when you leave
for like a week or something you come
back and you have just a mailbox that is
brimming with a bunch of a bunch of junk
mail and so yeah at the minimalists comm
slash day fifteen that's sort of the
fifteenth day of
ion's journey when he went through his
21 days of of minimalism
and there are some great resources there
DMA choice org opt-out pre-screened calm
and the world privacy formed org these
are all great ways for you to eliminate
not all but the vast vast majority of
the junk that is showing up in your
email box at home also your your inbox
too so we've got some some great
resources for you there
to deal with the clutter before it even
becomes one last thing when I'm thinking
about notebooks I know when I was
decluttering and going through the
packing party I had these old notebooks
from college yeah and I really valued a
lot of these notes that I took and I
thought to myself yeah if I ever want to
like reference this stuff I'm going to
hold on to it and what I found is a I
never referenced it sure and B when I
did try to go reference it the notes
were incoherent if you got old college
book notebooks from when you took notes
in class get rid of those it's that
you're not going to use yeah and if
you're absolutely tied to those you can
do what I did with a lot of photographs
but also a lot of paperwork so Ryan had
his packing party and I had a scanning
party see it turns out if you put party
at the end of anything Ryan shows up to
it and so well I did a scanning party
where I bought this little scanner
online as maybe 50 hundred bucks and I
guess so so much value out of a way more
than that fifty or hundred bucks you can
find the scanner that I use over at the
minimalists comm slash scanning and
there's that I talked about the whole
scanning party that I had there as well
but you can scan all your photographs a
bunch of different documents and this is
a scanner that you just start feeding
documents into this isn't one of the
old-school scanners where you have to
like lift the top and then hit seventeen
buttons and it scans one page in every
14 minutes no this is the thing you just
feed photos in and the cool thing about
having a scanning party bringing friends
over to do this bring a handful of
friends over or order some food some
drinks and have fun looking at some
photographs so that you otherwise
wouldn't use it if you're anything like
me and a lot of other people that I know
you probably have boxes of photographs
that are in the basement or attic
or worse you put it in these photo
albums and force the photo albums onto
your company and say hey do you want to
see the time that I went to Hawaii here
Ryan take a look at the trip right like
I remember I was there is it yeah and I
look at your photos but by scanning them
and putting them in a digital picture
frame and you can see the digital
picture frame I use there as well at the
minimalists comm slash scanning people
actually want to see it if people come
over and you have a digital picture
frame they start to actually look at the
photograph so Beckett did this with her
parents this Christmas for all of her
her siblings and her when we went out to
Minnesota to to her parents house for
Christmas they all pitched in and got
her this digital picture frame but then
they preloaded a bunch of different
photographs onto it and there's an
online service that you can upload more
in the future as well
so they put just hundreds of photographs
from all four families that are there
now and it was so much more meaningful
than just handing them a photo album
that was going to get stored on a shelf
somewhere what a cool idea yeah I would
I would definitely recommend having a
scanning party for all your documents
because here's the thing about that if
you're so worried if I need those
documents one day because I'm going to
get audited or whatever fine store them
digitally and get them out of your attic
your closet or underneath your bed or
wherever they are I just want to clarify
we're having a podcast party right now
right that's right okay that's how I got
Ryan the show I wanted to make sure our
weekly podcast party Franken in New York
City Frank has a question for us on
voicemail when does minimalism go too
far well minimalism go too far you know
I think when the focus becomes
solely on like how many items you own
that's one way it can go too far I mean
I think there are a lot of ways that
minimalism can go too far but I know
when I first started my journey it
seemed to be like this contest of who
could have the fewest items and when it
gets to that point you're kind of losing
the whole point right behind minimalism
it's not it's not about being a stoic
about depriving yourself it's not about
saying hey look at me I'm better than
the Buddha because I have less things
and he had right that's I think that's
where can go too far another way can go
too far is you know are you are you
doing things that aren't aligning with
your values and beliefs because for me
that's what minimalism really helped me
do it helped me help my short-term
actions
align with my long-term values and
beliefs and if I was to get away from
that and focus more on the items I had
or focusing on whatever and getting away
from those I think that is taking it too
far I do my best not to focus on
minimalism itself I use it as a tool you
know Ryan and I both know people back in
Ohio who have these massive tool sets in
their garage multi-thousand dollar tool
sets and that's fine if you use the
tools right but but when the point of
the tool set is to have the biggest best
tool set as opposed to fix what you're
attempting to fix and for me minimalism
was a tool that allowed me to fix my
life so I could start to focus on on
those values in our first book so Frank
I'm going to send you a copy of our
first book called minimalism live a
meaningful life in that book we talk
about the the five values and minimalism
was a tool that allowed me to not just
focus on those values but first uncover
those values because I had gotten to a
point in my life where I didn't know
what was important anymore and because I
didn't know what was important obviously
I couldn't focus on it unless I was
accidentally focusing on it and and so
by uncovering that which was important I
started to say okay my health is
important but wait a minute I'm 80
pounds overweight or my relationships
are important but of course my marriage
was ending so I forsook the people
closest to me and I said that writing
was important to me are pursuing a
passion was important to me but I wasn't
spending in time actually cultivating a
passion and I wanted to grow I wanted to
contribute to the world around me but
but I wasn't doing those things because
I was so focused on on so-called success
and achievement I was so focused on the
trinkets of success and minimalism was
was a tool I wasn't focused on getting
the biggest nicest toolset I was
focused on using the tool in order to
live a more meaningful life Heather in
Michigan has a question on voicemail for
us my question is what's next if I spent
so much time and energy on decluttering
and trying to get my life in order what
I'm wondering is what happens next what
are the next steps well I always feel
like I need to clean out another door
when I don't have all of this to focus
on I understand that it frees up my time
for my family in my life that will I
always feel like I should be going
through things or organize organizing
something else and so your question
about what's next before we get to that
let's talk about responsible
decluttering a responsible letting go as
I like to call it so you talked about
your mother and grandmother being
worried about the waste that is produced
by it by letting go and having all this
stuff that can be true when we joke
about you know you should just run a
dumpster and throw your stuff in it and
move on with your life that I wish I
could have done that you know what the
truth is we don't mean that literally we
mean that as a metaphor for moving on
but we are advocates of responsible
letting go what would be irresponsible
for me would be to hold on to all the
excess stuff because that doesn't allow
anyone to get any value from it if I'm
not getting value from them and no one
else's well then I'm just hoarding it
and I may have been a well-organized
hoarder but the operative word there was
was hoarding because the things that I
owned weren't serving a purpose for
anyone and so by letting go I realized
that other people would get value from
this so I started selling a lot of stuff
on eBay and Craigslist and started
donating a lot of things in a way that
allowed other people to to enjoy the
things I was no longer enjoying and so I
would encourage that and in terms of
what's next
it's really about finding something to
run to instead of just running away from
from the clutter which is is great and
and I commend you for that what are the
things that you want to run to and that
that's why for me I focusing more on
writing focusing more on my
relationships focusing on things that
brought me joy that made me feel a sense
of purpose and satisfaction in my life
was far more important filling my life
with those things as opposed to
continuing to run away from from the
clutter do our lives actually ever get
completely decluttered right I mean
there are so many responsibilities that
we have in our everyday lives especially
if you have a family I mean there there
is clutter that we constantly have to
manage getting rid of that physical
clutter certainly frees up time to deal
with all of other life's clutter so are
you going to move on to mental clutter
are you going to you know maybe
declutter some relationships so whatever
it might be but if we're not careful our
lives can become cluttered again so we
do have to yeah focus on just moving on
and looking for that new horizon yeah
now that I'm going to send you a copy of
our essay collection it's called
essential there are twelve different
chapters in there the the twelve
different areas of living a more
intentional life so it kind of starts
with the stuff it starts with minimalism
and material possessions and then it
moves on to mindfulness and mental
clutter and gift-giving and
relationships and all twelve different
areas of living a more intentional more
deliberate life and I hope you find some
value in that Heather our next question
is from Lee in Austin Texas what would
you guys say to a minimalist who wants
to take it to the next level
I've gotten rid of things I don't need
and I don't want I've read your books
I'm financially free I've played the
minimalism game with my friends I love
all of it but what help can I do am i
living the dream you want to take it to
the next level how do you do that for me
really it was about contribution like I
when I think about how did I move on
after that packing party when I got rid
of 80 percent of my stuff what did I
move on to and I contributed as much as
I could whether it was to the blog
whether it was going on tour
whether it was with my family and my
other relationships or whether it was
contributing to my health but certainly
that's that's one way to bring it to the
next level how much how much are you
contributing for me it was about
cultivating a passion I was an aspiring
writer for the longest time but I didn't
do a whole lot of writing I aspired all
over the place and so I decided you know
what I'm going to actually sit down and
do the work I'm going to Drudge through
the drudgery and so I would encourage
you to find something that interests you
whether that's tango dancing or writing
or scuba diving or snowboarding or yoga
and cultivate that into a passion it
doesn't mean it needs to be your mission
in life you don't necessarily have to
make an income from it do it because
it's something that you want to improve
at but it's also something that you want
to cultivate into a true passion of
yours and Lee you mentioned the 30-day
minimalism game I'll just clarify that
for the folks who don't know what the
heck that is so we all know that
decluttering is boring we found a way to
make it interesting with something
called the 30-day minimalism game and
here's how it works you can find all the
details at the minimalists comm slash
game but basically all you have to do is
find a friend or family member or a arch
enemy and what all you have to do is
agree to get rid of some stuff over the
course of the next month so on day one
of the month you'll get rid of each get
rid of one item day two two items day
three three items so it starts out
really easy to get you that momentum
that you need but over the course of 30
days it starts to get harder right on
day 15 you have to get rid of 15 items
day 20 20 items now whoever goes the
longest wins and if you both make it to
the end of the month you've both won
because you each gotten rid of about 500
items it's a really great start a really
great way to get momentum a really great
way to start letting go and hold
yourself accountable with someone else
Mullica in Washington DC has a question
what does minimalism look like on the
other side you guys talk a lot about how
to get there how to pare down your
possessions how to reflect on your life
and return what's important to you and
all that good stuff but what is life
like for a post minimalism minimalist
how do you guys
maintain your physical possessions and
life priorities in a minimalist way do
you guys regularly reevaluate all these
things kind of like a quarterly review
and start from you know get yourself
back to square one
or do you find that you just keep things
at their best unconsciously thanks
Monica so the first thing with
minimalism the thing that I started with
was a question how might your life be
better with less and by asking that
question it allowed me to identify the
benefits of minimalism but then I
started asking other questions questions
like does this thing add value to my
life and the cool thing about that is as
I went around to all of my material
possessions I kept asking that question
over and over and over does this thing
add value and in fact when I started
bringing new things into my life every
time I go to the store to to purchase
something I asked that question as well
will this thing add value to my life in
fact I asked that question so frequently
that it became less a habit and it
became more of an emotion in time and so
anytime I start to look at something
that I own or something I'm thinking
about acquiring I started asking that
question emotionally I had this
emotional feeling around that question
and then that bled over into other areas
of my life as well does this
relationship add value to my life and
really what that means is am I able to
also contribute to this relationship or
does this activity add value to my life
does this focus this thing I'm focused
on right now add value to my life and by
asking that question repeatedly I
started getting better answers and I was
able to adjust my life accordingly so
your question about what does minimalism
look like on the other side for me it
looks like more empowering questions and
so once you've simplified your life it
opens up gives you the opportunity to
ask questions like when did I give so
much meaning to my material possessions
and what is truly important in my life
why have I been so discontented who's
the person I want to become and how am I
going to define my own success I think
these are tough questions with with
difficult answers but for me they've
proven to be much more important than
just thrashing
I excess stuff and I feel like that if
we don't take time to answer these
questions carefully to answer answer
these questions rigorously then all the
closets we just decluttered all the
rooms we just decluttered they will be
brimming with new purchases in the
not-too-distant future yeah there is
never this endgame I think that the
towards the end of her question she
asked do things just kind of
subconsciously become perfect for me no
like I have to be conscious every single
day with every single decision that I
have I mean we're not perfect right but
but I am constantly in that mindset
whether it's getting a gift from a
relative that I like my mom came last
February she got me a couple gifts and I
wanted hold onto them because my mom
gave them to me and it meant a lot to me
but at the end of the day it wasn't
things that I really got joy out of or
that served a purpose so I kind of gave
those to someone else to use whenever
we're letting go it gives us a new
opportunity to start asking more
questions and so I think ultimately
living a more meaningful life if you
want to live a better life
start to ask better questions empowering
questions for so long I asked myself
disempowering questions why am I so fat
why am I so stressed why can't I ever
solve these problems though those are
self fulfilling questions but when you
start asking better questions how am I
going to define my own success man that
opens up for a lot better answer so if
you want a better answer ask a better
question yeah there are so many things
on the other side of minimalism and it's
it's different for each person and
asking those questions is going to help
you find out what the other side of
minimalism is going to look for you for
me it was less stress it was less debt
it was a cultivating passion yeah you
know I think we'd love to hear some some
comments from our listeners as well so
if you have a comment about next steps
about your post decluttering clutter and
and if you have any minimalism tips for
us how you handle your life after
letting go then leave us a voicemail 406
to
9 7 8 3 9 we'll air some of our favorite
comments and tips on the next episode
and if your voicemail selected we will
send you an autographed copy of one of
our books either essential or minimalism
live a meaningful life or my personal
favorite everything that remains ok
let's move on to our itunes comment of
the week all right this one is brought
to you by Moe Ellis the title of this
comment is more than advice on
decluttering it reads when I started
listening to this podcast I thought to
myself this is awesome
great for them not everyone can do what
these guys do but as I continued
listening and diving into what these
guys are really advocating in these
episodes I became truly inspired and
realized I too can live simply and
happily more than just advice on how to
declutter and downsizing this podcast is
great for real life applicable
mentalities and ways of living if you
find yourself discontented cluttered or
unhappy with the status quo or life
you're living this is the podcast for
you we can all live the life we want if
we're willing to put in the work awesome
thanks moe
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
everything that remains and I just want
to say thank you for that once you get
the book though make sure you minimize
it when you're done with it find someone
else who can get value from it doesn't
need to just sit on a shelf collecting
dust somewhere and thank you to everyone
else who has left us a comment on iTunes
as well those positive honest reviews
help us keep our simple living message
reaching more and more ears so make sure
you keep those comments coming
we'll keep selecting some of our our
favorite iTunes comments and reading
them on the podcast so feel free to get
extra creative with your iTunes comments
ok let's move on to our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we're
on twitter and instagram at the
minimalists and facebook.com slash the
minimalists our first question is from
Nina
nina asks i just got rid of four bins of
clothes most unworn with tags I know I
know that feeling I've been that yeah I
want to sell these clothes but I know it
will take time to sell how long should I
keep them with me if they don't sell
after they don't sell should I just
donate them may I remember going through
this with my packing party yeah it was
so stressful man like putting things on
eBay putting things on Craigslist uh-huh
figuring out what what I was gonna do
with those you know old cell phones that
I had piled up in a drawer because I
didn't want to just you know give those
out I was thinking to myself oh yeah
this phone's I could at least make
twenty bucks off of this or fifty bucks
off of this but what I what I quickly
realized was the opportunity cost of me
just giving all of that away it was the
money that I would receive for those
items and that money was sunk cost so
when I say opportunity cost opportunity
cost is if you have a decision between
an apple and an orange and you choose
the Apple then your orange is the
opportunity cost so I would encourage
you if it's stressing you out that much
just give it all away I promise you the
opportunity cost of the you know couple
hundred bucks that you might make off of
those clothes which if it's clothes a
couple hundred bucks is probably a
stretch right right it kind of depends
on the item the way I looked at it is I
had a lot of debt and so Nina what I
would tell you and anyone else who's
listening is if you have a lot of debt
or if you have any debt really and you
have some items that you can sell
relatively easily craigslist and ebay
became really great friends of mine for
the course of about eight months i would
encourage you to find the sort of the
80/20 rule right fine the 20% of the
things you're going to get the most
value from and give yourself a deadline
whether that's 30 days or 90 days or 120
days or whatever it may be give yourself
a deadline I personally would try to
pick 30 days so I can like Ryan get
those things out of my life and find a
way try very very hard to sell those
those items whatever you're trying to
sell within 30 days but after the 30
days are up no matter what be willing to
to let go
and move on with your life that way you
can make some money in the meantime use
all of that money to pay off any debt
that you have if you don't have any debt
and the stuff stressing you out though
let go of it immediately unless you can
very easily sell the stuff but make sure
you stick to whatever whatever mark that
you set out there for yourself be
willing to sell the stuff that you no
longer find value in but then be willing
to let it go no matter what even if it
doesn't sell yeah I mean there were
certainly some things I sold that helped
me pay off some debt like I sold a
big-screen TV for a couple hundred bucks
I sold you know a stereo system for a
couple hundred bucks and that was well
worth it but yeah I mean Nina don't
nickel and dime yourself to death that
can really be stressful I will I do have
one other idea I'll tell you there are
some like eBay shops I don't know where
you're at in the world but I know in big
cities they have people who will sell
your stuff for you I mean they'll take a
small percentage of it but you might
want to google that and see if that's an
option for you because that might be
worth it just to pay someone ten or
twenty percent of the of the sales to
have them put all of those items online
for you great question Nina let's move
on to our next question this one is from
Morgan any advice on how to take the
next steps in the direction of your
dreams I desire to leave the job I hate
and begin a career in a creative field
but it's scary thinking of the
financials of that leap of faith how did
you guys survive financially when he
decided to leave or were forced to leave
your jobs in the corporate world you
know I would just say just quit your job
and start a blog that's the worst advice
ever
yeah I think a lot of people think they
can do that though right like like it's
just so easy to you know leave and and
and do something that looks cool and
exciting and sexy and and and the truth
is that whatever you're going to do you
need to be running toward that and right
now I see Morgan as someone who is
running away from a particular situation
I tend that resonates with me because I
was I was getting to the point where I
was miserable I didn't necessarily hate
my job that's a very strong word
but I certainly wasn't passionate about
it and I was working 70 or 80 hours a
week every week 362 days a year just to
maintain a lifestyle that wasn't
bringing me joy and and realizing that I
needed to simplify my life in terms of
the financial side of things Ryan and I
wrote out an entire plan of how we
simplify our lives I'm going to go
through just some of the highlights of
that but you can find the entire plan
it's called financial freedom five
difficult steps to get out of debt
create a simple budget plan for the
future and regain control of your
finances it's a long title and it's not
misleading because it is five difficult
steps so the first step for me was to
set a budget I made a lot of money but I
spent even better money and so even
though I was making six figures and
spending more than that I had massive
amounts of debt and so the first thing I
had to do was to create a budget and I
what I call the ramen noodle diet which
I don't ever advocate actually eating
ramen noodles but but getting it down
your expenses down to the absolute
minimum if you have a bill and it's not
an absolute essential it's about
removing that from your from your life
and right and I broke that down into a
need want like list identifying what
your needs are what your wants are and
what your likes are so a need is
something I absolutely need I need food
I need a roof over my head
I need heat where I live and I need
these different things or things that I
absolutely need and and then the one so
things are that do add value to my life
you know I have an Apple music
subscription right now and it's a one I
really get a lot of value from it some
people have a cable subscription they
get a lot of value from there are a lot
of different things you get value from
and then there there's your like list
like I liked having satellite radio back
in the day I didn't get a ton of value
from but I liked having it and it was
kind of cool but it was costing fifteen
bucks a month and so I identified my
needs my wants my likes the first month
I got rid of a hundred percent of my
likes just let go of all of the likes
and then I let go of a hundred percent
of the once and the second one very very
difficult because a lot of those things
added value to my life but I realized
this was temporary deprivation as
was paying off my debts and being
willing to to let go of those once I
realized that once I got out of that I
could bring those things back into my
life that we're actually going to add
value again and then my needs I found a
way to reduce even my needs so I moved
into a smaller apartment I found ways to
reduce my utility expenses I got rid of
Internet at home and cable subscriptions
all these things I thought I needed the
Reimann you mentor a lot of different
people and it's amazing when you have
them put together a list of what someone
says they truly need some of the things
that make it to the need list are barely
even likes but we set up our lives to
think we actually need some stuff yeah
I'll get clients who will send me their
needs list and on their needs list is
well we've got you know for cell phones
and two Wi-Fi cards and then I don't
think you know you know think of myself
oh well they must have those Wi-Fi cards
because they don't have internet at home
or they can't get internet where they
live can't get internet where they live
or they need it for their jobs and yeah
there's not a coffee shop close to them
where they can use the internet and then
come to find out it's no they just have
it because they just feel like they need
to have the internet wherever they go
and we kind of talk to stuff like that
but you know regardless this the plan
that Josh and I lay out is it perfect
yeah it's perfect for Josh and I but it
may not be perfect for you but the key
here is have a plan and stick to it
so having having a plan that's the first
part and then sticking to it that is the
second part I mean that is definitely
what Josh and I did that will help you
overcome that fear of money or the fear
of finances yeah even a mediocre plan
that is well executed is much much
better than a pristine magnificent plan
that you don't take any action on
whatsoever so back to the plan real
quick once I had a budget together and I
set up sort of categories and boundaries
and and teamwork with the people in my
life and found ways to adjust that plan
I also may try to safety net within that
plan I think that's really important
having five hundred to a thousand
dollars set aside for any emergencies
that might happen you know if your your
tire blows or transmission goes out is
something where you need to have at
least a little bit of a safety net set
aside and so after I had that
that budget that plan for myself I I
started paying myself what does that
mean what means investing in my future
so finding a way to set aside even if
it's a dollar a paycheck because it's
about building that habit over time
right and I use something called
betterment and that you can also you
know if you have 401k at work or 403b
or any kind of you know sort of IR IRA
that you have an opportunity to
contribute to that's great but finding a
way to set aside at least a little bit
of money you know if your average person
starts in their 20s
setting aside just a little bit of money
we all have the opportunity to be
millionaires by the time you retire the
math is pretty simple everyone listening
to this has the opportunity to be a
millionaire within their lifetime by
setting aside just about 100 bucks a
month and so and that's not even
anything that is a high-risk sort of fun
I'm talking about the S&P 500 index
funds and so we outline that whole plan
and what I do in fact you can see my
entire retirement account down to the
dollar and screenshots everything that I
have at the minimalists comm slash
retirement the third the third part of
that plan is is getting debt-free I
spent the first 31 years of my life in
debt from age 18 I when I got my first
credit card until I was 31 years old I
had some sort of debt in fact at one
point in my late 20s I had six figures
worth of debt and so I want to be clear
about this there is no such thing as
good debt I'll repeat that for you Josh
there is no such thing as good debt but
what about what about I have to have a a
mortgage in about my school loans I got
to go to school I got a good school yeah
there's no such thing as good debt there
is some debt that is certainly
preferable to others I would rather have
a 7 year fixed rate mortgage than a 3
thousand percent payday loan at the
corner store but if there was a such
thing as good debt then you would
just want more and more and more you
would all be going and getting good debt
died I'd be swimming in good debt
I am debt free right now if you got an
idea of some really good debt that I
should get into send us an email let me
know yeah so find a way to get out of
debt we have a whole whole debt free
plan in that essay I talked about and
then I found a way to minimize by
getting rid of the excess stuff in my
life simplifying my life minimizing my
bills I was able to pare down my
lifestyle to where I was no longer
reliant on the same amount of income I
didn't need to pay the huge mortgage
payment or pay for the luxury cars I had
anymore and by being debt-free I was no
longer tied to the same obligations the
80 hour week obligation and so
minimizing was a big part of that and
then finally contribution I think this
one is is overlooked we we intend to get
what we give and by being willing to
contribute beyond ourselves even we
think we don't have a lot we do have
other resources other than money you
have time you have your attention so
back in Dayton Ohio Ryan and I would go
on the weekends and we'd go over to to
the house of bread which is the soup
kitchen over there and West Dayton we'd
spend time there or we do Habitat for
Humanity we do the food banks things
like that where you have the opportunity
to contribute beyond yourself not just
with money but with your time with your
attention understanding how other people
live allows you to understand that maybe
your situation that is so overwhelming
isn't actually that overwhelming at all
so that's really our plan I hope you
find a lot of benefit in and the details
of that before I move on to this next
question I do just want to clarify the
thing on debt because I know we're
ruffling some feathers with the debt we
always do when we talk about it sure
debt can be used as a tool there's no
doubt about that sometimes debt is a
tool that can be used to move you ahead
further in life but what Josh and I are
really trying to say what that is stay
out of debt at all costs if you can all
right this next question is from Missy
Missy writes I'm thinking that after I'm
done purging I might need a detox
program or something I'm actually
getting a high from clearing out 50 plus
years of clutter
is it depressing to finish you know I
won't for a few things first off
hopefully you'll never be finished
there isn't a list of 100 items every
minute lists should own to be happy but
I would say don't confuse minimalism
with the outcome minimalism is not the
outcome your goal here your objective is
not to be a minimalist
the objective is to use minimalism to
get that stuff out of the way get all
that junk that is cluttering up your
life out of the way so you can focus on
the things that you want in your path
yeah why did you start to declutter in
the first place was it so you could have
a nicer home and feel more comfortable
bringing people over and developing more
relationships was it to free up that
mental clutter so you had a room to take
on maybe a hobby that you've always been
interested in but get back to the to the
root of why you started to declutter in
first place and kind of ask yourself
where you're going to go from there
having again having a plan in this in
this scenario is another great idea what
is your plan after the decluttering what
are you going to do with that free time
what are you going to do with that freed
up space I start asking yourself those
questions what is your plan after the
decluttering what are you gonna do
alright let's move on to our next
question this is from Maddie what do you
do with items that you see as just in
case items but don't follow the 20/20
rule such as items you keep but don't
use often but are also harder to replace
let's clarify what the just-in-case rule
is for those of you who don't know you
can find a whole essay about that in our
book essential there's also a
description on our website the
minimalists comm /j i see the initials
of just incase so we often hold on to
things just in case we need them right
we won't let go because we might need
something someday and some far-off
non-existent hypothetical future and we
pack too much stuff on our vacations on
the remotest chance that that we're
going to need this thing just in case
and we hold on to so many things the
justification in our
to hold on to things that aren't
bringing us joy but maybe they will
someday and so I think someday is the
single most dangerous word that we utter
because it gives us permission to hold
on to things and the three most
dangerous words in the English language
of course are just in case because it
gives us permission to be irresponsible
with our hoarding and and so the
just-in-case rule ryan and i came up
with is anything that you are holding on
to just in case can generally be
replaced for less than twenty dollars in
less than 20 minutes from from where you
are and that rule has held up a hundred
percent of the time for us and it has
allowed us to let go of hundreds if not
thousands of just incase items because
we've realized that many of the things
that we thought we needed just in case
we've never actually brought back into
our lives affect and everything that
remains you wrote about there were five
things over the course of five years
between the two of us that we had to
bring back into our lives that were just
in case items with Maddie's question
she's asking about well what about the
just in case items I need these aren't
just in case items Maddie what you're
talking about this is a just for win
item now you might say well that's
semantics no there are I I will buy
toilet paper just for when I need it
it's not just in case I need toilet
paper I know that I'm going to need
toilet paper other people might have you
know extra pair of glasses because they
know they all are always losing their
there are sunglasses or eyeglasses and
you have a consistent record of doing
that that is a just for win item and I
try to parse out the two because I know
there are some things that I have that I
will will need at some point and a
snowboarding equipment for you is a
probably a pretty good example of that
yeah definitely um but I wouldn't say
that's a good example for everyone I
mean a good example for me it wouldn't
be a good example for me if I were to go
out and buy a bunch of snowboarding
equipment I'd be crazy because I don't
snowboard if you if you have a snowboard
in your house and it's been sitting
there for four years that's not a just
for one item right
that is a act now in snowboard or get
rid of item yeah totally great yet
alright next question is from Meredith
there is such an elated feeling after
minimizing a space completely
but it seems the feeling doesn't last in
the urge to purge becomes addicting when
you truly have little left to toss or
donate
how can you channel that obsession into
something beneficial I think getting rid
of our stuff is not the point and it's
important to remember that merit at the
point is what we do after letting go of
the stuff so so don't confuse the
letting go with the actual meaning there
isn't a meaning in the letting go the
meaning comes after the letting go if
you really love purging put an ad on
Craigslist where you'll help other
people purge their stuff what a great
idea that's a lot of fun to throw away
other people's it's so much easier let
go of other people's stuff too every
when Ryan was doing his packing party he
had the end of the kitchen cabinets full
of stuff and and it was so easy for me
to just like say all this is just trash
and he's like well wait a minute I need
that just the case of this just in case
and it's harder where we get tied to our
own stuff but letting go of other
people's stuff is pretty easy so you can
have a lot of fun with that if if you're
really feeling good about your your
purging activity you're super passionate
about purging then yeah that's that's
definitely a good idea next question
Alisha I find myself a lot more restless
now I feel like I have all this extra
time and I'm not sure how to fill it
should I pursue my passion I have no
idea what it is or where to start as of
now I'm trying to focus on strengthening
the Foundation's relationships health
etc but I feel like I could do so much
more
being quiet in the new space is harder
than I thought yeah I agree I think it
is difficult in everything that remains
there's a I think it's the sixth chapter
the title of it is the sound of
minimalism because after Ryan had his
packing party he had this huge 2,000
square foot condo 3 bedroom this massive
like 2nd living room with a very high
vaulted ceiling and when you remove the
stuff from the space it actually the
space itself sounds different and
dealing with that quiet it's almost a
different kind of quiet it's the the
sound of simplifying in a way and so
dealing with that space is difficult the
question is what are you going to fill
that space with we're not about getting
rid of all of your stuff and living in a
cage
if you want to do that it's fine I'm
sure there's appeal to some people
minimalism frost is allows us to live in
the modern world but in a more
intentional way so yes removing our
pacifiers is difficult and we don't
always want to do it but realizing that
you know the the security blanket is not
what brings you actual security your
your internal feeling about a situation
is what makes you feel secure yeah when
I left the corporate world that first
month going from you know hundred miles
an hour to a complete stop it was very
hard to deal with I don't want to say I
was like depressed but I definitely felt
a little foggy and wasn't exactly clear
on what I was going to do with all that
extra time and what I had to do was
rework my entire schedule my routine I
really had to switch it up I started
exercising regularly I started writing
more like I said at the beginning of
this podcast with the question about you
know what what activities did you give
up at first I was oh I'll just you know
play some Xbox and then maybe write a
little bit and and I just kind of was
trying to wing it but I really had to
get clear on what I wanted to accomplish
and how I was going to accomplish that
and we talked a lot about putting things
in your schedule putting things in your
calendar I know that's such a simple
suggestion but for me if it's in my
calendar like two things a it makes me
feel like I have to be there so it gives
me the sense of urgency and B it really
makes me question whether or not I want
to actually forego that appointment that
I set up for myself am I going to cancel
on myself so that that certainly helped
me to but yeah reworking your routine is
is definitely worth it I'll say I'll say
you know cultivating a passion reworking
a routine it's not easy it's it's it and
this is what we always talk about with
minimalism we're not talking about
living a perfect life or an easy life
it's a simple life but simple does not
necessarily mean easy Alicia said should
I pursue my passion I have no idea what
that is or where to start well then no
you shouldn't pursue your passion if you
don't know what it is our advice is
always cultivate a passion so I'm going
to recommend a book to you by Cal
Newport
it's a book called so good they can't
ignore you and it talks about the
benefits of finding something that
aligns with your interest in your values
and cultivating that into a passion over
time all right this is our last question
from Tori on hashtag ask the minimalists
could you give us some insight into a
day in the life of the minimalists you
guys talk about living your five values
but also focusing on one thing at a time
which seems contradictory so it would be
cool to see how these play out together
in your day to day lives you know when I
look at those five areas or those five
values I look at them like they are five
buckets so if I am feeling a little off
on a day I will look at those five areas
and see where am i lacking
I am only as happy as the least full
bucket and what I mean by that is is I
could have the greatest relationships
cultivating the greatest passions
growing and contributing but if my
health isn't up to par then those other
four values don't mean anything and the
same holds true with with the rest of
those so each day I am focusing
typically on one thing right now it's
it's writing my book it's focusing on
cultivating this passion and getting
this work out there tomorrow you know it
might be well I need to call my mom said
I haven't talked to her in a while and
feeling a little off because I haven't
put a lot of effort into my
relationships yeah I would say don't
don't don't confuse the task with the
value either some tasks can fulfill
multiple values at once if you go to the
gym with someone else every single day
well that can help improve that
relationship but it can also help
improve your health if you have a
writing partner with someone else you
can cultivate a passion you can grow
together and maybe you're helping them
out you're contributing as well and so
there are many tasks that fulfill many
values or all five values and Tori I'd
love to send you a copy of minimalism
love a meaningful life where we talk
about all five of those values but the
end of your question was can you walk us
through the average day of a day in the
life of a minimalist and about four or
five years ago I
they called a day in the life of a
minimalist for our friend leo bob alta
he is he's a dad with six kids he has a
whole minimalist family
he runs a website called Zen habits
dotnet and so you can find that essay
over the Zen habits dotnet slash a day a
da Y and I will read the first couple
sentences from that as a little teaser I
do not have a daily routine I no longer
need one I do however have habits on
which I focus every day don't get me
wrong I used to have a daily routine
before I quit my career to pursue my
passions and live a more meaningful life
and I hated that routine every day felt
like Groundhog Day awake to a blaring
alarm
shower shave put on a suit and tie spin
an hour or more and mind-numbing traffic
succumbed to the daily trappings of
emails and phone calls and instant
messages and meetings drive home through
even more mind-numbing traffic eat
something from a box in the freezer
search for an escape within the glowing
box in the living room brush my teeth
set the alarm sleep for five or six
hours start all over again in the
morning
that was life most days the same thing
over and over and over wash rinse repeat
so that was my initial routine my days
look appreciably different now and so if
you want to read about sort of my
average day it's built around habits
it's not built around a routine anymore
I will say this in the mornings I try to
focus on three things reading writing
and exercising and I wrote about that in
a different essay but you can find out
the minimalists comm slash morning
should write an essay on why I go to bed
at 3:30 a.m. yeah that's the thing it
doesn't mean that I I'm recommending
that for other people necessarily right
I am a lark and Ryan is a night owl and
I wouldn't try to conform to his
schedule certainly and I would not
expect someone who's a night out to
start getting up appreciably earlier
than they
because they're gonna it's going to set
the day up for failure so it's about
identifying what your pattern is and
then maximising find a way to optimize
your your day based on based on that
pattern all right let's move on to our
added value portion of the show this is
where we recommend something that has
added value to our lives recently and
since we're talking about next steps I
just got a copy and I'm in the middle of
reading it right now so I haven't
finished it I'm still going to recommend
it a guy named Colin Beavan who is in
our documentary and we he wrote a book
and a documentary had documentary as
well called no impact man where he lived
with a year for a year with essentially
zero waste I mean no electricity no
garbage and just this amazing experiment
that's not what I'm recommending what
I'm recommending is his new book it's
called how to be alive and to me that's
what minimalism is about is getting that
excess out of the way so you can focus
on how to be alive and I'll read a brief
excerpt from the back of the book here
how do you stop placing limits on your
potential impact how do you make your
choices really matter and everything
from your clothing purchases to your
career how do you find people who will
most support you in your quest for a
good life so earlier I mentioned asking
better questions these are great
questions and this book helps you
identify some of the questions the
chapter I'm on right now he has a
subtitle here says be too stupid to know
your limitations and take the first step
and so it talks about moving on I don't
when Ryan and I first started the
minimalists com had we had known at the
time that there were probably 20,000
other minimalist blogs it would have
been overwhelming and we certainly
wouldn't have become the the leaders in
this movement it was a bit of an
accident we were just trying to catalog
our journey and add some value to a few
people's lives hoping that someone could
give value from it and so how to be
alive one of the things to do is yeah
it's okay to be ignorant sometimes it's
just taking those actions taking those
steps and so hopefully a Collins book
will put a link to it in the show notes
but hopefully you can you can find you
can find it as a guide in fact the the
subtitle of the book is a guide to the
kind of happiness that helps the world
and that's really what I'm looking for
how do I grow how do
I how do I give yeah I would like to
recommend an accountability partner
since we've been talking about what to
do after the the decluttering find find
an accountability partner who can help
hold you accountable for those steps
afterwards let's say you want to start
developing or cultivating a passion for
writing well if you want to do that
you're going to have to write every
single day and not for a half hour
probably for two hours three hours I
mean you know I sometimes write for a
half hour or an hour I don't get very
much done in that time it usually takes
me about two to three but find an
accountability partner who maybe will
meet with you at a coffee shop and write
with you or maybe you guys just meet
later in the afternoon or have a phone
call about how the writing went totally
agree and I think that's one of the
reasons Ryan and I have been successful
in doing what we're doing here is
helping keep each other accountable we
have a pedagogical relationship we're
both mentors and mentees to each other
and we are able to sort of be the yin
and yang and for many of the things that
we do yeah and you know you could find
an accountability partner at minimalist
org you could find a local meetup group
in your area and see if you can find
someone to help you out and if there
isn't a meet-up in your area you can go
to the online city and there are about
1500 members on there who are helping to
inspire and motivate others but yeah
there's a lot of good activity going on
there so even if there isn't a local
meetup group in your town there are
still options for you let's move on to
our final segment we call right here
right now this is where we finally get
to talk about us and you know the sort
of what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist well first off we have
Tuesdays with the minimalist every
Tuesday in February on periscope and
Twitter 7:00 p.m. Eastern were answering
your questions live we've had thousands
of people join us at this point on
periscope and Twitter and we love
interacting it's it's a really great
time so join us 7 p.m. Eastern every
Tuesday in February for Tuesdays with
the minimalists also I already mentioned
our documentaries coming out made
we forth but Ryan and I are hitting the
road in May so the entire month of May
we're going to 14 different cities or
likely coming to a city near you you can
find all the tour dates that the
minimalists calm slash tour we hope to
see you there now a lot of cities are
selling out and or have already sold out
many of them sold out in 24 hours and so
we added second screens to a lot of them
and in some cases like in LA we found a
bigger theater and I think in Dallas we
found a bigger theater as well and so if
your city is sold out I think New York
and Seattle are get added to the waiting
list because you'll be first in line to
to get tickets for either a second
screening if we do a screening the same
night or if we get a bigger theater
you'll be first in line to be able to
pick up tickets for that and one last
thing I taught a workshop earlier this
month how to write better writing
workshop so I teach a four-week I called
a semester-long class and how to write
better org and and that is sometimes
time prohibitive for a lot of people and
so I have been I just started teaching a
one day workshop on Super Bowl Sunday I
forgot I'm super Bowl Sunday because I'm
not a big sports ball fan but we had
hundreds and hundreds of people show up
to that workshop so many people said so
many nice things about it was a two-hour
workshop I think ended up going three or
four hours and that that's that tends to
be how I roll so I have another two-hour
workshop coming up in June's it's a it's
a while away but it's June 26 and you
can get all the details for that and how
to write better dot-org finally here are
some voicemail comments from our last
episode happy this is present in
Portland Oregon and in response to your
last episode I just wanted to suggest
that people check out vintage used or
even family heirloom rings which are
often a great eco-friendly and human
friendly alternative to conventional
engagement rings hi Josh I'm Ryan this
is Kaitlin from Baltimore I wanted to
share a tip that helped in reducing
consumption of items and overall
collection of stuff so my tip is to live
by the by me once rule so this means two
things
number one if I buy this I am well I
need to replace it in a few months or a
few years or even my lifetime does the
manufacturer offer okay
errors or can it easily be fixed there's
actually a website by anyone's comm that
only includes products with a lifetime
guarantee so when I'm buying an item I
want it to last as long as possible
ideally my lifetime and number two if I
buy this item am I going to get ordered
it in a few months or years is this a
timeless classic I am that I will keep
forever in this case I'm taking mostly
of clothes and decorative items or
furniture but you can also apply this to
things like children's toys or kitchen
items in the short term you'll probably
spend more on your by neots items but
it's okay if you're truly following that
rule since you will only have to buy it
once hi my name is Elizabeth and I'm
from Portland Oregon I was just calling
because your last episode you talked
about engagement rings and I just had an
idea for people who may still want that
but we could turn it into something
that's more valuable in an experience so
something my husband and I did is we
found a place in our state that you can
actually go mind your own stone and so
we both are rock hounds that's something
that were really passionate about so we
went out and we mind our own wedding
systems and then we had them cut and set
into rings and I mean the whole
experience was probably less than two
hundred dollars for both of our rings
and it really was we were able to create
something that was really valuable and
meaningful for us and had a really
memorable experience hi this is Luis
from across I just had a comment about
Kaitlyn's question from the stuff
episode I was thinking about in terms of
cooking like if you wanted to simplify
or not collect so many things you could
focus on a specific cuisine or I don't
know style of food it would be like them
for instance for Ryan focusing on a
certain kind of snowboarding like just
freestyle as opposed to racing or
backcountry kind of snowboard riding or
what resonate
for me was in musically music focusing
on one instrument and getting really
good at that so it gives a more
opportunity to collaborate with other
people and you could say the same thing
about food where you specialize in one
thing and maybe you have a friend who
specializes in another and you can mix
and match and enjoy dinner parties
together alright Joe that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists we are doing a couple
episodes we're doing one on careers and
one on money so especially if you have
questions on career and money we'd love
to hear those questions or comments as
well about careers and and money or
passion and money could be another way
to look at or maybe you call it mission
and money so we're doing two separate
episodes coming up on that if you have a
any question for us you can give us a
call 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it every little thing
that you got ahead
every little thing that you got
you gotta reach for you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your tea
you